[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du Grand JT des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité avec la une cette
semaine une technologie en plein
développement le drone marin TBO la
chaîne du groupe le télégram nous fera
découvrir un projet étonnant de bateau
autonome pas de capitaine à bord mais de
nombreuses applications embarquées
voiture cycliste piéton ils sont des
milliers à l'emprunter tous les jours le
pont Jacques Chaban-Delmas fête ses 10
ans à Bordeaux cet ouvrage exceptionnel
est encore aujourd'hui le plus grand
pont levant d'Europe TV7 la chaîne du
groupe sud-ouest nous dévoilera les
coulisses de cette super structure
singulière un museau à la place d'un
test PCR et si les chiens détectés la
covid-19 grâce à leur capacité olfactive
nos meilleurs amis à quatre pattes
pourraient bien nous aider après venir
l'apparition de maladies un sujet de
weetv la chaîne de la Voix du Nord dans
un instant dans ce journal et puis en
fin de JT des images spectaculaires pour
une traversée hors du commun sur une
sangle et 200 mètres au-dessus du vide
une association vient de parcourir plus
d'un kilomètre dans les Pyrénées un
nouveau record dans un décor
époustouflant comme nous le montrera via
Occitanie sur place
[Musique]
voilà il y a-t-il un capitaine dans le
bateau après les airs et la terre la mer
se met-elle aussi au transport autonome
en Bretagne un partenariat entre
université et entreprises privées vise
au développement de drones marins encore
en face d'essai ceci pourrait s’avérer
précieux dans de nombreux domaines
surveillance recherche ou encore
sauvetage en mer les précisions avec ce
sujet de Tébéo la chaîne du groupe
télégramme en Bretagne
dans ce bateau blanc pas de pilote mais
plutôt une deuxième embarcation elle non
plus sans pilote ou presque c'est depuis
cette camionnette au bord de la rade de
Lorient que ces deux engins sont dirigés
avec le bateau directement à distance
d'un kilomètre 5 à peu près le bateau
complètement autonomie qui esquive tout
ce qu'il voit sur ses caméras sur radar
son ais
il fait sa mission et puis le pilote qui
est derrière pour checker aider un petit
peu le bateau sur certains passages
difficiles des rentrées de port des
choses comme ça et cette automatisation
est une innovation co-conçue avec deux
sociétés cier et im solution autour du
lipstick de l'université Bretagne Sud
qui rend le bateau totalement autonome
et c'est de faire la détection
d'obstacles sur l'eau dans le but
d'amener d'être capable de télé opérer
le drone sans le voir en visuel pour
essayer de dire cette objet qu'on a
détecté sur l'eau grâce à la caméra on
le place à 100 mètres devant nous avec
un angle de 30 degrés pendant ce temps
l'une des entreprises partenaires rend
le bateau plus stable et économique
favorisant ainsi la collecte des données
la troisième société quant à elle
fabrique l'ensemble des systèmes
automatiques dans l'idée on a un gros
drone qui est équipé avec des caméras et
des capteurs permettant de détecter les
obstacles et il sécurise le petit le
plus petit drone qui va faire son
travail de manière autonome sur l'eau et
les applications opérationnelles peuvent
vite trouver leur place tout ce qui est
nouveauté tout ce qui va sur l'autre
tout ce qui pourrait servir au sauvetage
il faut pas qu'on reste à côté la SNS
aiment le monde militaire ou celui de
industrie autant de secteurs qui demain
pourront agir ou intervenir à distance
ou de manière plus sécurisée
voilà et de technologie il en est bardé
lui aussi le pont Jacques-Chaban-Delmas
à Bordeaux fait en ce moment son dixième
anniversaire la structure la plus
importante en Europe est une prouesse
technique qui fait l'objet d'une
attention particulière depuis son
inauguration peinture moteur câble c'est
l'ensemble des équipements que les
agents doivent choyer pour la sécurité
des usagers des équipements plus ou
moins visibles que vous fait découvrir
Yves en branchis pour TV7 la chaîne du
groupe sud-ouest à Bordeaux
30 000 véhicules 3000 cyclistes et 2000
piétons traversent chaque jour depuis 10
ans cet ouvrage qui relie la rive droite
à la rive gauche un trafic dense au-delà
des espérances qu'il faut parfois
interrompre à la saison des croisières
ici nous nous trouvons sur le poste de
commande du pont Chaban-Delmas c'est
d'ici que le ferment le le pont à la
circulation vélo piéton voiture on
manœuvre depuis l'ordinateur le les
mécanismes une manœuvre de 30 minutes
effectuer 837 fois en disant pour 428
passages de bateaux l'entretien du pont
Jacques Chaban-Delmas est alors une
priorité et tout commence dans l'antre
de la travée le ventre ce qu'est son
métallique de 2500 tonnes l'entretien
c'est juste un contrôle de la qualité
des soudures
la charpente métallique a un contrôle et
un maintien en bon état de
fonctionnement du déshumidificateur qui
bloque le développement de la corrosion
à l'intérieur en dessous de la Garonne
c'est à l'abri des regards que se trouve
la pièce maîtresse voici l'une des deux
embasses du pont à l'intérieur un poste
de commandement de secours et surtout
ces deux moteurs de 180 chevaux dont un
qui fonctionne l'autre en secours plus
un réducteur et deux tambours pour
pour tirer sur les contrepoids et lever
la travée tous les quatre ans un
entretien complet du pont est réalisé
mais d'ici là il faut s'occuper du
graissage mécanique des pouliers et des
câbles il doit y avoir 4 interventions
par an d'alpinistes ils s'accroche on a
des points d'accroche et il descendent
le long du au-dessus de la poulie donc
pour rejoindre les câbles juste au
niveau de la poulie un travail
indispensable qui permet d'améliorer les
process à chaque passage de bateau le
pont était fermé une heure 40 en moyenne
en 2014
contre 1h10 aujourd'hui une belle
progression mais qui n'empêche toujours
pas les embouteillages aux heures de
pointe
une histoire originale comme on aime
vous les raconter dans le grand JT des
territoires dans les Vosges un habitant
aujourd'hui décédé a décidé écoutez bien
de léguer sa fortune à sa commune un leg
en forme de cadeau de plus d'un million
d'euros tout de même une aubaine pour la
collectivité qui devra néanmoins
respecter la volonté du défunt que cet
argent finance la construction d'une
maison de retraite les détails avec
Ludovic brésilia et Titouan boiteux
ainsi qu'un Didier pour rejeter
télévision
ici nous sommes donc en face de la de la
maison de la Maison de l'Enfant les
terrains qui peuvent être visés c'est
ceci c'est une belle histoire que
raconte depuis quelques jours le maire
d'Anne Hould à proximité de
saint-denis-des-vosges l'histoire d'une
donation d'un de ses administrés Claude
Florence décédé en février 2021 à l'âge
de 85 ans Claude Florence était ouvrier
propriétaire toutefois de parcelles de
terrain sans descendance directe l'homme
qui vivait modestement allégé à la
commune la coquette somme de 1 million
260000 euros nous sommes avec à la fois
un don nous sommes à la fois avec un
avec un terrain maintenant il nous
accorde de travailler pour pouvoir faire
au mieux un leg que le généreux donateur
avait évoqué de son vivant pour en
savoir plus direction la mairie à nous
de compte 3200 habitants mais aucune
maison de retraite pour l'instant car
Claude Florence avait en effet demandé
que son don participe au financement de
la construction d'une maison
d'hébergement pour personnes âgées
dépendantes qui avec un pavillon pour
des personnes atteintes de la maladie
d'Alzheimer en amont on peut pas
annoncer des chiffres ou faire naître
vraiment des de dire ça va être un grand
projet alors qui qu'il sera un petit peu
plus petit parce que aujourd'hui il faut
mesurer aussi que les coûts des
bâtiments des matériaux vont être
différents donc il nous faut examiner
tout ça un million 260000 euros c'est un
peu plus que le budget annuel de la
commune pour financer ses travaux
d'investissement en plus des 2 millions
d'euros dédiés au fonctionnement une
somme très conséquente donc et une belle
histoire qui trouvera son épilogue dans
quelques années une chose est sûre la
structure qui sortira de terre rendra
hommage aux donateurs c'était son
souhait et à sa sœur décédée elle aussi
un établissement qui s'appellera donc
Annette et Claude
trottinette électrique vélo scooter vous
avez dû forcément le constater ces modes
de transport se multiplient partout dans
nos villes et s'ils sont évidemment
pratiques encore faut-il connaître la
législation et le code de la route près
du Mans la police municipale procède à
des opérations de prévention et de
répression notamment aux abords des
établissements scolaires un reportage
d'Enzo Maubert pour lmtvart
bonjour Depuis le mois de décembre
l'opération est de plus en plus courante
à Sablé-sur-Sarthe la police municipale
contrôle les trottinettes et les vélos
vous avez des lumières avec vous oui
ces agents constatent de plus en plus
d'infractions et bien souvent aussi une
méconnaissance de la loi alors ça a de
l'éclairage l'obligation d'assurance aux
règles de circulation et c'est vrai que
de plus en plus les gens laissent la
voiture pour un autre moyen et c'est un
petit peu l'anarchie parfois sur le
niveau circulation pour ce jeune homme à
trottinette pas de souci tout est en
règle il a même un système de
signalisation pour d'autres ça coince
par contre il manque le petit moyen
réfléchissant à l'avant comme vous avez
à l'arrière en vélo les feux sont
obligatoires tout comme les catadioptres
les freins et le port du gilet
réfléchissant la nuit interdit aussi les
écouteurs en trottinette électrique on
ne dépasse pas 25 km/h et les trottoirs
sont interdits l'âge minimum pour
conduire et de 12 ans en cas de
non-respect c'est la contravention ça va
de 35 euros à 135 en passant par 90 ça
dépend d'infraction relevée
ces contrôles je faut d'abord misé sur
la prévention on va pas être dans la
répression immédiate mais en tout cas
une fois que cette prévention a été fait
en plus on relait beaucoup
d'informations sur nos réseaux sociaux
on communique énormément sur la sécurité
je pense qu'à un moment bon si on
comprend pas avec la prévention on est
obligé de faire de la répression bonne
journée à vous au revoir lors de cette
opération personne n'a été verbalisé en
décembre dernier la police avait relevé
39 infractions sur 49 engins contrôlés
chien et santé et si en plus d'être nos
meilleurs amis les chiens étaient aussi
les garants de notre santé la réflexion
peut prêter à sourire pourtant vous
allez le voir elle relève aujourd'hui de
la réalité grâce aux chiens renifleurs
dans l'Oise deux d'entre eux viennent de
participer à une opération de dépistage
de la covid 19 dans une maison de
retraite objectif développer le recours
à nos compagnons à quatre pattes dans la
détection précoce de pathologies telles
que le cancer et permettre ainsi des
prélèvements moins invasifs pour les
patients Jérémy houblon pourri au TV la
chaîne de la Voix du Nord les a suivis
regardez
une intervention pour le moins original
dans cet EHPAD aujourd’hui Joy berger
malinois des pompiers de l'Oise ne
recherchent pas de personnes sous les
décombres et encore moins de produits
stupéfiants non la chienne est capable
de détecter le virus de la covid le
chien prend la phase montante du virus
le somnum comme l'épaisseur et la phase
descendante voilà donc on est prévenu 24
heures voir 48 heures avant que la
personne va être positif au à la
covid-19 s'il y a un prélèvement un
pompier qui est marqué on va pouvoir
l'isoler ça permet de pas fermer une
caserne entière quoi dans ces cônes des
compresses prélevées sous les aisselles
d'une vingtaine de résidents d'un geste
simple et bien moins gênant que le
classique PCR en prélevant au niveau
axillaire ou au niveau de la nuque comme
vous avez vu c'est très peu invasif pour
la personne le chien en un coup donné va
pouvoir nous dire si oui ou non il y a
le passage du virus en quelques secondes
les premiers résultats tombent sous les
regards stupéfaits des résidents avec le
projet nozaye l'école vétérinaire de
Maisons-Alfort entend bien développé
l'usage de chien dans le domaine
biomédical notamment dans la détection
précoce de pathologies telles que le
cancer
un avantage pour les gens parce que
c'est des prélèvements qu'on va faire de
sueur ou d'urine par exemple qui sont
pas douloureux du tout pas invasif et le
deuxième avantage elle est champs
sociétales c'est l'aspect financier
c'est à dire que quand vous mettez des
gens dans une filière de dépistage où
vous allez accumuler des IRM des
biopsies des examens histologiques etc
ça coûte très cher pour l'heure une
trentaine de chiens ont été formés en
France prochaine étape pour mosaïs la
création d'un centre de recherche et
développement afin d'étendre ses
formations
allez continuons de nous intéresser à
nos aînés dans ce journal avec écouter
bien une sortie en discothèque et oui
aussi étonnant que cela puisse paraître
une telle activité était proposée en
Bretagne à plusieurs résidents de
maisons de retraite et comme pour les
plus jeunes il fallait danser pour se
dépenser et s'amuser seuls différences
pas de virer nocturne mais toute une
après-midi pour enflammer la piste
Natasha Astor pour TVR
non ce ne sont pas des cocktails
alcoolisés mais bien des jus d'orange
car ce jeudi après-midi s'est sorti
discothèque pour les résidents de 10
EHPAD du Pays de Vitré on est venu là
pour s'amuser pour danser c'est la
première fois que j'ai en discothèque et
je suis très contente je suis venu avec
mon amoureux et j'ai tenté deux tango
ils sont 90 résidents et une trentaine
d'animateurs à fouler la piste du Gossip
club à 12 euros l'entrée les boissons
soft sont à volonté et la musique bien
variée de la musette à Jean-Jacques
Goldman parmi les danseurs Jacqueline
était l'ancienne gérante de la
discothèque La Pergola une institution
dans le grand Ouest ouverte en 1975 qui
pouvait accueillir près de 4000
personnes moi j'étais Bambino à l'époque
et j'allais danser là-bas et j'étais
toujours adminératrice de michet qui
avait toujours des des belles toilettes
des belles chaussures toujours
souriantes et cet après-midi c'est
vraiment un plaisir de pouvoir recevoir
un pichet et de lui rendre à notre tour
la joie de pouvoir danser
l'établissement s'est adapté son et
lumière tamisées on laisse le
déambulateur de côté pour swinguer
histoire de vivre une deuxième jeunesse
cet après-midi dansant intérêt pad sera
certainement reconduit pour le plus
grand bonheur des résidents
voilà nous vous en parlions la semaine
dernière le procès de Bobigny est resté
dans l'histoire comme un événement
majeur pour l'avancée des droits des
femmes en France l'avocate Gisèle Halimi
à qui il était rendu un hommage national
le 8 mars dernier avait notamment plaidé
il y a 50 ans contre la pénalisation de
l'avortement un engagement mis en scène
le temps de quelques représentations
théâtrales à Paris par la troupe
conférence des compagnies et donc vous
voyez quelques images à l'écran et parmi
les intervenants de l'époque
réinterprétées en 2023 l'écrivain Simone
de Beauvoir était joué par l'avocate
vise à vos na Moulonguet écoutez-la
revenir sur son rôle et l'histoire de ce
procès pour les droits des femmes
l'idée extraordinaire de ce procès parce
que c'est un procès historique c'est que
Gisèle Halimi a voulu mettre en
accusation la loi sur l'avortement elle
a dit aux femmes qui se présentaient
vous allez revendiquer votre acte vous
allez dire que vous n'êtes pas des
criminels vous êtes victime d'une loi
criminelle et c'est en ça que c'est très
intéressant c'est en ça qu'elle a
retourné l'opinion et qu'ensuite on a
tracé une voie pour permettre à six
bonnes veilles de faire passer la loi
sur l'avortement elle serait plus de 2
milliards à être jetés chaque année en
France les serviettes hygiéniques ont un
impact non négligeable sur
l'environnement certains plastiques qui
les composent mais très notamment
jusqu'à 500 ans à se dégrader alors pour
préserver la planète sa santé et faire
des économies le recours aux protections
périodiques réutilisables ne cesse de se
développer exemple avec cet atelier
consacré à leur fabrication suivi par
Lina bradedine pour Télé Grenoble
regardez
car les protections jetables présentent
de potentiels risques pour la santé on a
du coton bio pour la partie qui va être
proche des parties intimes on a aussi du
tissu absorbant donc ça peut être du
dans celle de viscose là on travaille
sur des matières intenses de viscose
mais ça peut être du coton bio voilà on
utilise le pull pour le la partie
imperméable et du coton classique pour
l'autre la dernière partie qui est à
l'extérieur et dans sa vie une femme
dépense 1500 à 2000 euros avec des
protections jetables le lavable permet
d'économiser environ 200 euros sur cinq
ans et encore plus quand on fait
soi-même et si elle est lavée dans les
règles la durée de vie d'une protection
réutilisable est de 5 à 10 ans
elles ont une durée de vie de plusieurs
décennies les tentes cabanons sont
devenus depuis plus de 60 ans de
véritables références dans leur domaine
l'entreprise installée à Dunkerque et la
dernière fabricante de tentes 100%
française un savoir-faire précieux qui a
su vous allez le voir traverser les
époques et s'adapter aux attentes de ses
clients reportage au cœur de l'usine
cabanon de Frédéric lois et de Myriam
Nami pour astv la télévision locale de
Grande-Synthe
c'est une manufacture qui date de 1959
d'abord implanté à Bailleul avant de
déménager ici en zone industrielle de
Petite-Synthe en 2005 cabanon est le
dernier fabricant de tente 100% made in
France Pierre cyrulus dirige cette
entreprise depuis qu'il a racheté la
presse totalité des parts en 2013
cabanon embauche aujourd'hui un peu plus
de 50 salariés on est dans un produit
plutôt haut de gamme donc on s'adresse
aux campeur averti ou professionnel
on a des produits qui sont respirants
qui s'intègrent dans le paysage vous
voyez que l'étoile sont en général beige
gris et ce sont des produits qui durent
dans le temps des tentes qui durent
conçus et cousues à la main des modèles
sans cesse renouvelés mais aussi des
caravanes pliantes et dortoirs des tipis
des tunnels et autres 4500 tentes
sortent de ces ateliers chaque année et
70% de la production est exportée le
camping à levant poupe mais il a surtout
beaucoup évolué cabanon lui a su
s'adapter en innovant avec de nouvelles
tentes répondant aux besoins des
particuliers et de l'hôtellerie de plein
air
depuis 64 ans cabanon perpétu ce
savoir-faire qu'elle transmet de
génération en génération avec les
départs à la retraite ou les jeunes
mamans couturières qui partent en congé
maternité ou prennent des temps partiels
pour s'occuper de leurs enfants cabanon
cherche toujours à recruter des
couturières l'entreprise veut essayer de
mettre des personnes à la couture qui
n'ont jamais cousu avec l'idée de créer
un centre de formation
vous en écoutez sûrement plusieurs lors
de vos trajets en voiture ou aux
activités chez vous les radios ne
cessent d'accompagner le quotidien des
Français et au milieu des fréquences
nationales bien connues de tous des
stations locales et régionales
réussissent elles aussi à se frayer un
chemin jusqu'à nos oreilles à Limoges
Flash FM affiche une très belle réussite
depuis sa création il y a 20 ans entre
ouverture de nouvelles fréquences et
recrutement Alain Druon pour cet animos
c'est intéressé à cette aventure
indienne regardez
il est 9h vous êtes peut-être déjà au
taf en ce moment bon courage peut-être
sous la couette pour les plus chanceux
associatif dans les années 2000 Flash FM
est devenu la radio musicale régionale
qui domine les sondages à Limoges et en
Haute-Vienne proximité simplicité semble
être les clés de la réussite quand on
écoute flèche FM on a de la musique
qui s'adresse à un grand nombre qui est
aimé par nos auditeurs et puis de
l'information locale avec une forte
présence sur le terrain sur les réseaux
sociaux Flash FM s'écoute du Poitou au
Limousin de Poitiers à Brive pour faire
court les émetteurs Corréziens devant
démarrer prochainement
attention ça c'est l'info de Limoges si
on appuie là on a la force de Guéret et
si on a plus l'un on a l'info route de
Poitiers société privée la radio n'a
qu'une seule source de financement la
publicité commerciale contrairement à
certaines autres radios qui peuvent être
financés publiquement ou qui peuvent
avoir des subventions une
radiocommerciale comme la nôtre n'a ne
touche aucune subvention que ce soit de
l'État et aucun autre financement à part
la publicité pour faire face à son
développement Flash FM recrute avec dans
l'immédiat un poste de journaliste pour
voir à Limoges d'autres suivront dans
les prochains mois
[Applaudissements]
voilà restons dans l'univers des médias
dans cette édition pour vous signaler la
parution dans vos kiosques à journaux de
deux des éditions spéciales du point
l'hebdomadaire s'intéresse notamment à
l'avenir de Rennes cette semaine la
capitale bretonne qui connaîtra dans la
prochaine décennie une véritable
métamorphose urbaine nous dit le
magazine une révolution qui concernera
aussi la deuxième ville de France
Marseille et cette fois-ci ce sont les
transports qui connaissent de nombreux
bouleversements dans la cité phocéenne
le point qui consacre également vous le
voyez sur ces images d'un dossier
spécial au secteur immobilier pour les
villes d'Aix-en-Provence et de Marseille
tout à fait autre chose de la couleur
dans les rues pour égayer l'horizon
prenons désormais la direction de la
Martinique dans cette édition où l'une
des rues de Fort-de-France est au centre
d'un projet original la création d'une
fresque géante pour habiller le bitume
les couleurs chassent ainsi le gris
grâce au pinceau d'un collectif espagnol
et de bénévoles les précisions avec ce
sujet de Maxime Luke pour via TV
Martinique
des travaux peu ordinaires dans cette
rue commerçante de Fort-de-France la
circulation a été interrompue et les
passants regarde d'un oeil positif le
début de cette oeuvre artistique
on a vu que c'était piéton et quand on a
vu ça c'est super bien vraiment belle
idée au bout des pinceaux un collectif
d'artistes venus de Madrid habitué à ce
type de projet nous réalisons des
fraises depuis plus de 20 ans et nous
voyageons dans le monde entier grâce à
cela nous avons notre camp de base à
Madrid mais en réalité nous passons
notre vie à l'étranger pour faire des
graffitis comme celui-ci aux côtés des
artistes confirmés il y a également des
bénévoles
avec juste des centres couleurs donc
c'est fait horizon c'est le mot qui sera
marqué sur le bitume coloré un choix des
habitants et des commerçants là pour
nous c'est la première étape de ce qu'on
veut faire et de ce qu'on veut montrer
en tant que regarney Pagès
il y a quelques mois j'espère ce
chantier artistique durera jusqu'à
vendredi prochain les volontaires sont
les bienvenus
voilà qui n'a jamais joué aux Playmobil
la petite figurine iconique a marqué
plusieurs générations depuis sa création
en 1974 un succès planétaire qui n'est
pas réservé vous allez le voir au seul
enfant une exposition consacrée à
l'univers Playmobil était organisé il y
a quelques jours près de Metz et parmi
les 3000 visiteurs présents de nombreux
adultes ont replongé dans leur souvenir
d'enfance comme a pu le constater Emma
facetti pour moins LTV
caractérisée par sa coupe légendaire ce
personnage de 7,5 cm a séduit le cœur de
ce grand enfant de 24 ans Arnaud baton
collectionne les Playmobil depuis l'âge
de 2 ans ce qui est intéressant pour moi
de d'avoir toute cette toute cet
échantillon de deux pièces et pouvoir
agrémenter chaque chaîne chaque scène
pardon différemment et pouvoir mettre en
scène ses univers de vie ces scènes de
vie cette exposition de 70 000 pièces
regorge de nombreux trésors comme cette
maison victorienne commercialisée en
1989 toute ma collection a une valeur
sentimentale parce que voilà c'est c'est
quand même une collection qui qui est
immense mais si je devais choisir qu'une
seule pièce ça serait cette pièce là
parce que vraiment elle est magnifique
on a voilà toutes les tous les petits
détails au niveau des fenêtres les
rideaux à l'intérieur on a également des
tapisseries il n'y a pas d'âge pour
s'émerveiller devant ses 17000 figurines
ces adultes regarde c'est cette
miniature avec des yeux d'enfants
du côté des visiteurs on retourne à pas
en enfance donc on a tous été à jour
collectionneurs de jouer notamment de
PLAYMOBIL
donc ça correspond bien à l'univers des
Playmobil 49 ans après sa création la
petite figurine en plastique raconte
toujours des histoires
allez on referme ce journal avec ses
très belles images venues des Pyrénées
où vous le voyez plusieurs personnes ont
traversé une station de ski à l'aide
d'une corde placée 200 mètres au-dessus
des pistes des sensations garanties pour
un défi spectaculaire à réaliser sur
plus d'un kilomètre l'occasion de nous
émerveiller devant ces vues splendides
et cette prouesse voilà c'est la fin de
cette édition merci de nous avoir suivis
on se retrouve très vite pour une
nouvelle édition du Grand JT des
territoires au revoir à tous
[Musique]